all right y'all gather round gather
round welcome gentlemen what a beautiful
and blessed day for an auction
all right y'all get on up there put that
whip down and see what happens Oh
straight up I don't care what plantation
I end up on I'm straight staging a
revolt in this mother yeah we have a lot
B and lot C $3 on lot a $4 5 $5 going
once twice three times sold lot a goes
to the man in the black I mean good yeah
I'm glad I didn't get sold cuz I don't
want to be owned by another human being
whoever buys me they better kill me the
first day I'm gonna go buck wild on the
whole operation next one get up bone up
there now $6 on lot a $7 8 9 $9.00 going
once twice three times sold
okay well you have to buy that there's
no brainer I mean I got huge massive
individuals that's two of me anybody
would buy here I buy that dude my
question is how'd they catch him next
okay $2 on lot a - dollars going once
twice three times sold see now that
surprises me that is interesting to say
the least well it just seems like at a
certain point it's like do they even
know what they're looking like the whole
criteria seems a little inconsistent -
brother get a latte next oh here we go
pleasure
give them hell all right okay eight
dollars on la de go along splice
treetops holes no not true what'd you
just say
that's gobbledygook okay I can't be true
cos what can this do do look at him what
could he pick a cotton plant is like
this tall I'm saying no offense brother
I'm just saying no sense taken what am I
wrong is he's not short esurance but you
are actually short in real life in the
world didn't mean awful I will not have
my reputation tainted sellin superficial
bigoted slaves superficial did that
really just come out of your mouth
that's it
this auctions over it's not over well
I'm strong y'all I'm very sure I can
sleep in a bucket I'm fast I got stamina
I don't look it but I know magic my
worst quality is that I'm a
perfectionist ever mention this docile
I am agreeable to a fault you should
have seen the dude who asked me get on
the boat when we came over not a violent
volley no big deal never seen a boat in
my life
[Music]